les amendements dont il est question ici
porte sur la suppression d'une
disposition adoptée
par la commission des lois qui ne
prévoit pas la réintégration des
personnes non vaccinées
je tiens à le dire parce que la plupart
des interventions qui ont eu lieu
était soit contre la réintégration
soit pour la réintégration ce n'est pas
de ça qu'il s'agit vous pourrez
d'ailleurs renouveler votre prise de
position dans un instant parce qu'il y à
bien des amendements qui exige selon des
modalités différentes d'ailleurs la
réintégration je n'ai pas proposé
l'arrêtera gassion la commission des
lois la commission des lois n'a pas
adopté d'amendements
procédant à la réintégration
le sénat a voté l'obligation vaccinale
le sénat a également voté la suspension
d'activité des personnels soignants
principalement qui n'étaient pas
vaccinés dans le but de protéger les
malades des personnes âgées les
personnes handicapées en établissement
médico social je tiens à ce que les
choses soient claires
parce que c'est ainsi qu'elle se
présente
mais à la différence des vaccinations
qui sont nécessaires pour l'accès à la
fonction publique hospitalière
la vaccination contre le coc vide est
une vaccination temporaire les
personnels qui n'ont pas voulu se faire
vacciner n'ont pas été licenciés
leur lien avec le service public
hospitalier ou avec une clinique ou un
établissement médico social privé n'est
pas rompu
la suspension du contrat de travail est
par définition temporaire et non
définitive que tous nos collègues qui
pense qu'on pourrait ne jamais
réintégrer ces personnels le sache bien
le droit
applicable avant la proposition adoptée
par la commission des lois
exclu qu'il reste suspendue pendant
toute la vie si on avait voulu les
écarter définitivement de leur métier
pour des raisons qui tiennent à une
sorte de morale qu'un personnel soignant
ne devrait pas refuser de se faire
vacciner parce qu'ils exposent des
patients un risque que tous ses
collègues sache bien que cette exigence
morale tout à fait respectable qu'il
voudrait voir imposer n'est pas dans le
droit positif actuellement applicables
donc tous ont vocation à reprendre un
jour leur travail est ce que nous
proposons nous ne devons proposer qu ils
le reprennent maintenant
je réponds non
est ce que nous devons prévoir les
conditions dans lesquelles le
reprendrons je réponds oui et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que la commission des lois
a fait parce qu'actuellement c'est un
pouvoir discrétionnaire du gouvernement
ne pouvons faire confiance au
gouvernement ou ne pas lui faire
confiance en tout cas sa liberté
d'action est totale et nous avons pensé
face à un sujet qui effectivement ne
concerne pas de nombreux agents
mais un peu plus de 2000 c'est à dire
très peu d'argent à l'échelle de
l'emploi de plus d'un million de
personnes au sein du service public
hospitalier et des cliniques privées eh
bien ces quelques centaines de personnes
elles ont droit à des égards elles ont
droit à ce qu'on s'occupe d'elle
on n'a pas voulu qu'elle contamine la
cause est entendue mais enfin elles ont
une vie une famille un revenu à acquérir
par leur travail il est bon d'organiser
leur retour et de ne pas laisser ce
retour à la discrétion du gouvernement
nous voulons que une décision médicale
s'impose au gouvernement et c'est la
seule chose que nous ayons décidé alors
nous avons dit je pense que c'est
pertinent que c'est la haute autorité de
santé qui prendra la décision de dire ça
y est enfin libre le coc vide c'est fini
l'obligation vide maximale n'a plus de
sens pour le coc vide et puisqu'elle n'a
plus de sens le lendemain monsieur le
ministre vous serez encore si vous ne
prenez pas le décret autorisant la
réintégration et pour être sûr que cette
haute autorité de santé
se prononce
au moment opportun et que les choses ne
traînent pas dans la situation se sera
absolument améliorer nous disons que la
haute autorité peut s'autosaisir que le
gouvernement peut la saisir que le
nouveau conseil qui se substituera au
conseil scientifique peut la saisir mais
aussi que les commissions des affaires
sociales de nous deux assemblées
auxquelles je crois monsieur alain
millions qui s'est exprimé tout à
l'heure peut faire confiance comme nous
tous pourront saisir la haute autorité
de santé c'est tout rien de plus et rien
de moins et c'est déjà un pas en avant
pour dire à ses personnels moi je pense
qu'ils ont eu tort de ne pas se faire
vacciner mais il avait la liberté de ne
pas se faire vacciner car on ne vaccine
pas de force en france en revanche nous
avons voulu mettre à l'abri les malades
les personnes âgées les personnes
handicapées et donc ils n'ont pas pu
rester au contact de ceux ci pas plus
que les pompiers qui actionne les
secours d'urgence et par conséquent
nous sommes maintenant je crois dans une
situation je le dis très sobrement où il
y a un chemin vers la réintégration de
ces centaines d'agents qui n'ont pas
reçu une punition mais qui se sont vu
imposer de ne pas faire prendre de
risques aux malades et aux personnes
vulnérables y un chemin nous le créons
mais nous le créons pas de manière
fantaisiste en disant scrogneugneu je
décide aujourd'hui mois
sénateurs
de les réintégrer parce que ceci n'a pas
de sens
je crois que la décision doit être
médicale elle le sera
[Musique]